j'accueille ce julia channel
[Musique]
au sport
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le journal du
hard pour cette première on ne se
connaît pas encore très bien mais je
vous offre tout de suite un cadeau de
bienvenue une sélection défi qui
cartonne sur la planète 14 actrice
approuvé par le public et sélectionnées
par notre spécialiste
henri gigoux qui les a classés en trois
catégories les ventes classiques les
beautés naturelles et les lolitas 14
raison de se faire une opinion et plus
si affinités c'est au coeur de paris
dans le jardin des tuileries que tout le
monde en a parlé à retrouver julia
channel
l'ancienne star du porno en période de
reconversion il fait son footing
on va dire du sport depuis une vingtaine
d'années ça permet d'évacuer de voilà de
réfléchir se remettre bien quoi donc
c'est important
c'est pas que physique qui en même temps
j'ai vu qu'ils n'ont plus fragile plus
un temps non plus donc il faut aussi que
je montre son corps est toujours son
outil de travail
mais désormais julia la sulfureuse est
actrice et chanteuse elle vit à londres
et c'est l'enregistrement de son nouvel
album qui la ramène à paris
pour l'heure c'est l'inspiration qu'elle
cherche dans l'une des librairies les
plus en vue de la capitale
elle réfléchit tôt photos du livret qui
accompagnera son album
[Musique]
bettina rheims
là par contre je connais bien puisque
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec
elle j'adore son travail ça j'adore tous
les livres de photos sur le m'a dit ça
c'est pays dogon j'essaie de trouver
j'essaie de trouver un petit peu
l'univers quoi essayer de faire quelque
chose de différent
j'aimerais faire beaucoup de noir et
blanc image quand même assez choc mais
mais jamais tomber dans la vulgarité
quoi ça j'adore ça c'est le genre de
noir et blanc que j'aime
julien profite également de son passage
à paris pour revoir ses amis et
aujourd'hui elle déjeune avec celle qui
fut également son attaché de presse
[Musique]
vu sur l'arc de triomphe à l'office pour
le retard est connu après 13 ans est un
droit
quel genre de femme volontaire courageux
sont tous très courageuse persévérante
et
sensible vraiment je sais ce que je veux
donc c'est vrai que c'est difficile de
déléguer à des gens parce que
je suis souvent pas contente c'est vrai
que j'ai appris très vite et très jeune
à tout gérer moi-même et j'adore ça en
même temps et après je travaille avec
des gens où je sais que ça va exactement
correspondre à ce que j'ai mais on se
connaît très bien voilà quand on se
connaît très très bien il n'y a aucun
souci direction montreuil sous bois en
proche banlieue parisienne où son
manager l'attend pour l'enregistrement
de son prochain titre une reprise à
nouveau single une reprise d'un morceau
des années 80 la chanson est une reprise
qui parlent d'amour un tube de celle
affichée sur une standing et une section
mode et fieux a tué à ce que ken fois de
lanzhou et j'espère une boîte
hennessey de meknès crimes ont eu tort
wouah lycée raymond naves oscar morales
et ps2
pour julia channel leur est venu de
poser pour les photos de l'album un
aérodrome pour décor un body léger très
léger et un ventilateur pour un effet
maximum
de toute évidence julien ne mise pas que
sur les textes pour vendre ses nouvelles
chansons
[Musique]
souhaitons à julia channel que son hôte
d'or deviennent victoires de la musique
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
julia channel bienvenue son plateau de
tout le monde a parlé alors julie avait
été le 3 novembre 1973 à paris sous le
nom de julia saut c'est ça père
d'origine malienne peut exactement maire
demande alors vos parents sont issus de
familles aisées votre père né à bamako
est arrivé à paris après son bac pour
faire les beaux-arts mais sa famille a
connu des revers de fortune il faut dire
aussi qu'ils préféraient faire la fête
que suivent des cours non c'est vrai que
c'était plutôt une période bizarre envie
de faire la fête
voilà aux parents étaient assez inadapté
à la vie un cd des artistes un peu un
peu bohème
oui mais j'étais passionné mais un peu
autodestructeur combat disons qu'ils ont
préféré à privilégier leur relation
26 salles avec leurs enfants votre mère
picoler non
oui des fois elle disparaissait
plusieurs jours malheureusement oui
c'était assez fréquent des descentes
fugue auquel on s'habitue à force on
sait bien su qu'au début ça un petit peu
déstabilisante et après ça fait partie
du quotidien donc à votre père était
violent avec elle ouais ça arrivait
alors quand vous naissez ils ont déjà
plusieurs enfants qui sont placés à la
dasu dans les familles d'accueil et vous
êtes la seule qu'ils ont élevé quoi
ouais savent qu'ils ont gardé la
dernière bon voilà c'est je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai jamais d'explication enfin
je crois que je suis passé entre les
gouttes 1
voilà un jour pendant les vacances voyez
votre mère je faire sauter par un voisin
voilà c'est des choses dont j'ai parlé
dans mon livre parce que dans le livre
ça fait partie de toute ma vie
évidemment il fallait en parler pour
expliquer peut-être des choses se sont
passées après et dans mes choix oui
voilà alors quand vous naissez vos
parents occupe une chambre de bonne à
250 francs par mois passage ramer dans
le 18e
ensuite il déménage dans une hlm à
neuilly plaisance en seine-saint-denis
c'est la cour en dise est encore à mon
époque la scène sony s'était pas encore
la sainte famille d'aujourd'hui c'est
encore assez paisible un y avait pas
grand chose à faire mais
vous existe quand même pas trop mal quoi
alors le drame de votre enfance et quand
votre frère laurent qui était un petit
peu votre ange gardien se jette par la
fenêtre du 7e étage
ouais pourquoi on sait parfum n'a jamais
su ce qu'il n'y a pas eu d'explication
mais ah ouais c'est ça a été très très
dur ce que c'est moi qui l'a pris en
premier c'est moi qui a dû l'annoncer en
fait à mes parents enfin toute la
famille donc c'était à 17 ans c'est un
peu un peu dur mais bon vin disons que
je les accepte et en me disant qu'il
était mieux comme ça c'est ce qu'ils
sont et est donc là j'ai là il a fait le
juste respecter sa volonté quoi alors
pour vous aussi le monde est dur parce
que vous devez vous construire tout seul
et éviter les pièges qui guettent les
jolies filles dans les cités ouais bah à
cette période là ça allait encore parce
que j'étais en fait j'étais un garçon
manqué jusqu'à 18 ans voilà jusqu'à 18
ans j'avais beaucoup de mal à accepter
ma féminité donc je cachais tout je
cachais mes fesses ou des pulls je
cachais messin je parlais comme un
garçon j'avais une démarche de garçons
je voulais surtout éviter d'avoir une
interaction justement avec ces gars ont
très tôt vous découvrez le pouvoir que
votre beauté exerce sur les hommes vous
décidez de vous en servir vous êtes
ambitieuse volontaire et rapidement le
cinéma porno vous apparaît comme un
moyen d'échapper à votre milieu et
connaître une ascension sociale rapide
oui c'est vrai c'est
c'est ce qui s'est présenté cinq ans
j'aurais pu faire autre chose et comme
je suis pas peureuse assez téméraire
j'aime bien faire des choses un petit
peu décalé je les fais j'ai foncé tête
baissée mais c'était pas y réfléchit
c'est à dire que tout ce que j'ai fait
dans la période où j'ai fait des films
c'était calculé penser à la gav un vrai
il y avait une vraie stratégie entre
guillemets derrière vous étiez pas une
victime quoi bien à ce moment-là julias
au devenir du lit à chanel et vous
débutez comme mannequin de charme en
posant pour une marque de maillots de
bain ensuite des magazine érotique
playboy penthouse 8 à 18 ans je ne vais
pas mon corps je le trouvais trop fort
mais avec une trop grosse poitrine des
trop grosses fesses la photo était comme
une thérapie qui m'a permis d'accepter
mon physique et j'ai fini par me plaire
ça m'a donné la confiance parce que
forcément quand on pose devant un
objectif on commence à s'aimer
donc ça a bien marché alors le premier
pour nous vous tournez c'est dans la
boîte échangiste d'alban serré week est
en fait vous l'aviez vu allemand serré
dans un film porno pas ma première scène
ça se passait au clos quitté la boîte
d'alban serré à l'époque
et donc quand je suis arrivé il a ouvert
la porte et je suis tombé nez à nez avec
sa tête
je me suis demandé mais j'étais déjà vu
quelque part et c'est après que je me
suis rappelé que je l'avais vue étant
petit quand j'avais surpris le voisin
qui est à côté qui nous prêtait la
maison en train de regarder un film avec
allemand serait donc ça faisait un tout
en un un truc
évidemment vous gagnez 7000 francs en
une journée c'est énorme
parce que voilà vous vivez dans un hlm
vous rêvez d'être célèbre pour rêver
d'une vie de strass de paillettes et le
x représente pour vous un tremplin
social comme la nôtre ouais comme un
autre canal où la boxe
oui c'est en même temps bon c'est vrai
que c'est atypique mais bon si après
tout dépend comment
et si on sait pourquoi on le fait si on
maîtrise qu'on n'est pas victime ya pas
de chèques un fils qui va vite le sexe
m'intéressait pas plus que ça vous étiez
pas spécialement excité qua non non non
c'était enfin quand je travaillais je
travaillais quoi je serais pas là pour
m'envoyer en l'air
donc je travaille et je serai la main je
rentrais chez moi après qu'ils se
laissent filer 8 le premier tournage
j'ai pas vraiment réalisé ce qui se
passait en fait non j'ai pas réaliser
parce que ça a été très vite donc c'est
après coup quand je suis retourné à la
fac
4e bon quand même alors au début vous
pourriez faire qu'un film et les filles
nouvelles sont très demandés évidemment
dans le dans le porno
et puis alors vous avez des propositions
qui vous intéresse et puis vous vous
continuez propositions sont arrivés tous
les côtés et puis finalement je suis
parti tout de suite aux etats-unis et
puis en fait la majeure partie de ma
carrière elle a été fait là bas quoi
est-ce qui vous a rendu mondialement
célèbre
oui tout ce dont je rêvais le xbla elle
a permis voyager vivre dans les endroits
sublime luxueux participé à d'immenses
fait effectivement j'ai eu accès à tout
ça mais là ça peut paraître un peu
peut-être fou mais là l'ambition
première j'ai fait ça c'était quand même
pour arriver à une passion et la passion
ma passion c'était la musique
donc c'était peut-être un peu fou de
dire que en passant par le hic ce qui
arrivera la musique
mais finalement c'était pas si fou que
ça alors en 18 mois vous avez tourné 140
films en europe aux usa avec les
meilleurs réalisateurs du monde et là
vous rencontrez rocco siffredi vous est
tombée amoureuse
non disons que baffe enfin disons quand
on rentre dans ce milieu là
tout le monde était là un recours aux
cours et c'est un peu un peu le dieu
quoi alain delon du pommier ou quoi dans
93 malgré la proposition du studio
américain va arriver vous mettez un
terme à votre carrière en fait vous
partez faire un reportage au congo
brazza sur le sida pour votre vidéo est
là où dit j'ai vraiment eu peur atroce
quoi j'ai tu me suis retrouvé aux côtés
de malades du sida en fait mais vraiment
comme ça quoi et pas non plus pas des
malades qui étaient dans des baux
hôpitaux ou bien le confort et tous
étaient vraiment dans les conditions
atroces
c'était des bébés enfin j'ai vécu ça
pendant quinze jours et c'est là que
j'ai pris conscience que voilà qu'il
fallait peut-être arrêter de jouer à la
roulette russe et que c'était une
maladie atroce enfin surtout à mon
époque le préservatif était pas du tout
de rigueur sur les plateaux donc enfin
c'est quand on y pense c'était quand
même super risquer quoi est peut-être
passé entre les gouttes c'est miraculeux
- certains acteurs qui avaient des
certificats médicaux pouvait tout bidon
oui parce que ça veut pas dire grand
chose qu'une seule protection qui qu'ils
soient réels ces préservatifs y en a pas
d'autre oui j'étais trop angoissé cette
zone est impossible de tourner j'essaie
de rallier tous les producteurs tous les
acteurs
dire voilà à venir on se met tous
ensemble on dit qu'on refuse de tourner
s'il ya pas de préservatifs et
finalement je me suis retrouvé tout ça
j'ai dit bamba ciao
voilà j'ai arrêté comme ça que j'ai
arrêté et vous et des copines font
choper le das des copines on met des
gens que ça des actrices que je
connaissais de nom comme ça oui oui mais
pas mal à vous arrêter le x donc sans
regret et vous présenter le journal du
hard
voilà vous aviez votre célébrité de du
porno c'est une nouvelle célébrité qui
s'offrent à vous comment a réagi votre
entourage quand vous avez eu cette
notoriété en fait au début toute la
période où j'ai tourné je n'avais pas de
contact avec les gens de mon entourage
parce que j'avais tout vous fermez
j'avais tout couper je voulais pas avoir
à expliquer aux parents le savent et oui
savait mais on n'avait pas de contact
d'accord que j'ai complètement je me
suis mis en comme dans une bulle
j'ai fait mes trucs et après une fois
que je suis sorti du milieu là j'ai
commencé à reprendre contact avec les
gens quelles ont été vos relations avec
les médias cette époque j'ai jamais eu
de souci avec les médias réellement
parce que
je sais pas peut-être que j'avais une
image assez bonne
il n'avait pas trop envie de me taper
dessus et puis à petit ils n'avaient pas
non plus trop de raison puisque j'ai
toujours assumé ce que je faisais vous
avez de l'argent ont fait pas ça pour
devenir richissime c'est plus pour
essayer d'en faire quelque chose après
parce que c'est pas c'est pas le cinéma
traditionnel c'est pas les mêmes cacher
c'est pas ça n'a rien à voir
alors l'amour comment ça s'est passé
dans tout ça l'amour oui parce que
quelqu'un qui sort avec vous quand même
à nous à se justifier
le gars qui avec julia channel on peut
même nous a expliqué qu'en fait c'est
une fille formule avec toi comment ça
s'est passé
ben je dois dire que j'ai quand même
pour l'instant toujours eu de la chance
surtout à cette époque là j'étais avec
quelqu'un qui m'a épaulé pendant toute
la période je travaillais et encore
après quand j'ai arrêté donc ça m'a fait
ça m'a beaucoup aidé d'abord comme un
soutien parce que j'avais personne sinon
et puis par la suite j'ai quand même en
général jamais eu trop de problèmes je
suis quand même tomber sur des personnes
qui n'avaient pas trop peur d'assumer
même si ça les pousse à me gêner plus
moi pour eux gisèle était sûr ça ne fait
pas chier ta mère et voilà après mes
façons les choses elles se sont déjà sur
la table n'a pas rebuté des hommes dont
vous étiez amoureuse non
quel était le meilleur moment de cette
époque l'époque du hard je dirais c'est
tout ma période deux états ou en général
parce que déjà je découvrais l'amérique
je suis arrivé là bas je parlais pas un
mot d'anglais
j'étais tout seul c'était c'était quand
même à 18 ans à se retrouver en
californie tout seul j'ai eu des très
bons souvenirs quand même les pires
moments c'était sur un tournage en
italie où c'était juste où je me suis
barré carrément quoi c'est vrai je
voulais pas tourner avec les gens qui
étaient là voilà il y avait une ambiance
qui était juste pas agréable et avec des
choses que vous aviez pas envie de faire
quand on me demandait juste que j'avais
besoin de faire je ne faisais pas
c'était non quoi ah ouais ouais je n'ai
pas être une serpillière or ensuite bon
journal du hard ça vous ennuie un peu
vous faites une potiche qui vient
producteurs vous dites on me laissait
rien faire avec te manquer parce que moi
j'étais venu avec l'idée d'amener des
choses de faire une émission un peu
dynamique et toujours et que c'était
plan-plan l'audience en faire un truc un
peu plus jeunes mélangez sexe mais plus
funky quoi et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que c'était pas du tout ce qui
était prévu donc je me suis retrouvé à
lire un prompteur je pouvais même pas
changé trois lignes c'était un peu à
grenoble est donc basta et je suis
reparti sur mcm
j'étais d'abord me souviens j'ai fait
des choix aussi dans des clubs
ouais partout en europe partout où je
suis allé partout même au japon et alors
il ya un incident assez symbolique de
votre changement de vie celle incendie
oui c'est à dire que là il ya un
incendie chez vous et tout ce que vous
aviez accumulé ce que vous appelez votre
butin de sexe ouais en fumée c'est fou
ouais c'était bien ça faisait un peu
comme une sorte de purification un peu
pour voilà enlever le passé et puis
repartir sur des rats pas enlever parce
qu'il sera toujours là et ça fait partie
de moi mais pour repartir sur des
nouvelles bases quand tu vas voir sega
cd v dc cassette ces photos voilà les
awards et machin partis en fumée s'était
pas pu mal quoi mais c'était grâce à ces
incendies n'ont en effet pas mourir mais
gimont sauviat je ne suis pas à 8
minutes près j'étais morte quoi
aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgiques de la
grande époque
ah non non je suis nostalgique de rien
du tout parce que ma vie
et la vie que je pense que je rêvais
d'avoir sais maintenant que je lai quand
je chante quand je suis en studio
voilà c'est ça gérer rêvais de ça depuis
que je suis j'ai cinq ans j'avais de la
rancune contre certaines personnes
l'époque n'ont aucun respect pour la
fonction et si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je n'aurais pas su ma carrière en
france
je l'aurais fait uniquement aux états
unis voilà le jour vous allez mourir
qu'elle voulait qu'on écrive sur votre
tombe à julien elle était drôle et très
belle surtout voilà on pourrait dire ça
aussi merci ce serait heureux de
rallumer la lumière soit vous remercie
les pointures de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu